[Musique]
je suis designer et aujourd'hui je suis
venu pour vous parler de design mais pas
que exactement de design pour me
présenter mon travail en fait de
designers c'est que je fais pas des
chaises je fais pas des voitures
je fais des logos je travaille pour des
sociétés pour des collectivités
territoriales dans l'industrie dans la
mode dans le prêt-à-porter dans la santé
ou dans l'alimentaire bref je fais plein
de choses différentes
est ce que vous vous avez des idées un
petit peu de ce que celle du design
certainement je vous pose la question
pour vous c'est quoi le design des
objets des voitures souvent quand on
parle de design on dit le design c'est
esthétique le design c'est ergonomique
j'ai quelques exemples à vous montrer
les voitures par exemple c'est
esthétique souvent on dit à regard de la
forme de cette autonomie une chaise
c'est ergonomique on me dit regarde
comme c'est confortable cette chaîne une
application mobile
ça peut simplifier la vie des gens le
design ça simplifie la vie des gens ce
qu'on me dit moins souvent c'est le
design c'est aussi une méthode pour
réfléchir
on appelle ça aujourd'hui le design
thinking la pensée design en français ça
peut permettre de trouver des solutions
pour vous simplifier la vie
est ce qu'on me dit moi souvent c'est
que le met le design c'est aussi
éthiques
eh oui en choisissant les chaînes de
production ou les objets qui nous
entourent les matériaux de construction
en respect avec notre environnement
on peut changer nos sociétés mais voilà
pour les quelques fans de design qui
sont dans l'art dans la salle j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle mais j'ai aussi une
bonne nouvelle
la mauvaise c'est que le design ne va
pas changer nos sociétés ouais je suis
désolé c'est un designer qui vous le dis
donc c'est honnête
le design va pas changer nos sociétés
alors du coup la bonne nouvelle c'est en
fait c'est vous qui allez changer nos
sociétés et oui c'est vous si si vous
allez changer nos sociétés en rêvant et
oui en rêvant je vais vous expliquer mon
histoire personnelle
tout commence il ya quasiment jour pour
jour il ya 30 ans j'avais 10 ans et j'ai
fait ce dessin que vous voyez alors
soyez un peu indulgents j'avais 10 ans
et j'arrive en sixième et la
l'enseignante lance un sujet bateau pour
pour des enfants de 10 ans
dessinez votre maison en fait ce sujet
bateau pour moi ça a été une vraie
angoisse une boule au ventre un peu
comme la boule que j'avais en coulisses
avant de venir vous voir
voyez ce petit truc pourquoi parce que
la maison de mon père la maison de mes
parents
elle ressemble à ça
ouais alors aujourd'hui voyez j'ai un
fils car a le même âge que moi à
l'époque qui rentrent en sixième et
quand je vois comme il est en pleine
uniformisation où il faut faire tous de
la même façon il faut rentrer dans le
moule il faut avoir le même cartable que
son voisin
il faudrait avoir les mêmes basket que
son voisin quand j'ai dû dessiner cette
maison je me suis dit je vais avoir une
mauvaise note
on va me prendre pour un illuminé on va
me prendre pour un hurluberlu
et qu'est ce qu'on va penser de moi je
commençais à me faire remarquer alors
que je viens d'arriver au collège et que
je peux vous dire que quand on est un
bébé artistes avec des lunettes un peu
binoclard on essaye de ne pas trop se
faire remarquer mais voilà l'enseignante
était une originale et hammami la note
de vent et donc j'ai dû venir devant au
tableau pour parler de mon dessin et
parler de cette maison un peu étrange
avec des murs jaunes des murs roses fluo
sur des pilotis avec des hublots
j'ai dû venir avec mes 10 ans expliquer
ça à vous devant mes camarades déjà j'ai
du mal à vous en parler aujourd'hui donc
imaginé à l'époque
est-ce que vous avez déjà ressenti ou
certainement ou es ce que vous avez déjà
été félicités pour avoir fait quelque
chose de bien de re dit ouais
certainement à l'école au travail votre
femme peut-être si vous avez bien fait
le ménage
ouais moi ça m'arrive jamais mais est-ce
que vous avez déjà été félicités pour
avoir fait quelque chose de différent
sans doute mois ce jour-là l'enseignante
mais a fait m'a mis en lumière devant
toute la classe et elle m'a en fait
presque orienté pour devenir designer
devant toute la classe
à ce moment là elle m'a donné le droit
d'être légitime pour devenir un artiste
pour devenir un créateur
alors je dois vous avouer un truc c'est
que évidemment quand on a une maison
comme ça c'est qu'on est tombé dans la
potion magique quand on était petit mon
papa est designer mon frère et designers
mon grand père était un artisan et j'ai
grandi dans ce milieu créatif depuis
tout petit donc potion magique
familial mais aussi potion magique avec
une méthode éducative particulière je
pense que j'ai eu la chance et c'est
quelque chose que j'avais envie de vous
dire j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une
méthode éducative complètement
différente de la vôtre
j'en suis quasiment sûr je prends un
exemple d'après vous c'est quoi le point
commun de ces trois objets je voulais
décrit un pinceau pour ceux qui voient
pas au fond de la salle au milieu c'est
une sorte de vieil ordinateur des années
90 avec des touches encore oui avec un
photoshop qui tourne dessus un vieux
photoshop de l'époque et puis le dernier
document c'est un document administratif
chiant qu'on n'arrive pas à lire c'est
normal même quand on est à côté on
n'arrive pas à lire c'est un d'un
extrait de kbis c'est un document pour
réaliser une société bon évidemment vous
n'avez pas d'idée en point commun c'est
sûr si la création non presque presque
en fait pour ces trois objets quand j'ai
appris à me servir d'un pinceau à l'âge
où normalement on suit des cours avec
des professeurs qui nous apprennent à
faire des pleins et des déliés qu'ils
apprennent à faire des gros traits à
faire des aplats affaire dé la vie quand
j'ai dû mettre les mains sur
l'ordinateur la première fois de ma vie
où plus tard quand j'ai fait une société
à chaque fois je me suis tourné vers mes
parents vers mon frère en l'occurrence
pour le pinceau et je lui ai dit et bros
comment on fait pour se servir de ce
truc là et vous savez ce qu'il m'a dit
m'a dit fais comme tu veux y a pas de
méthode fait ta méthode ce sera parfait
pour l'ordinateur même chose plus tard à
l'âge de 15 ans je demande à mes parents
comment on fait pour se servir de ce
truc photoshop ça marche comment et mon
immeuble
alors peut-être qu'ils n'avaient pas
envie de s'ennuyer mais avec un gamin
qui postaient qui poser trop de
questions
mais m'ont dit ouais non vas-y fais
comme tu veux débrouille toi tu vas
trouver et du coup en faisant ça ils
m'ont donné envie de créer ma propre
méthode d'inventer en fait ma propre
façon de créer aussi bien avec un
pinceau en le trempant dans la peinture
et en faisant du dripping un peu à la
pologne ou en essayant de faire des gros
geste ou avec photoshop d'inventer des
méthodes créatives pour l'extrait kbis
même chose quand j'ai commencé à vouloir
faire une société j'ai pas fait une
société comme tout le monde j'ai décidé
de faire une start up
il ya une petite dizaine d'années j'ai
créé parmi les premières start up en
france un modèle vraiment nouveau pour
inventer des sociétés 100 m 1 euros de
ma poche à l'intérieur mais voilà je
dois vous avouer un truc être créatifs
ou devenir créateur ou devenir
entrepreneur c'est pas forcément quelque
chose de très simple j'ai beaucoup douté
dans les années 90 quand mes parents ont
connu une crise financière que tout le
monde connaît en france dans le monde
entier
cette crise financière s'est transformée
en crise familiale puis divorce et ce
moment pour moi ces moments où tout le
monde équilibré parti en vrille c'est le
moment où je me suis mis à douter alors
que j'avais j'étais j'avais grandi dans
un dans un équilibre parfait de création
où tout est possible où j'avais le droit
de toucher à n'importe quoi et de
l'appréhender de la façon je le
souhaitais à partir de ce jour là je me
suis mis à douter
je me suis dit jamais je serai créatif
jamais je serai entrepreneur j'ai
associé cette crise et ce divorce ce
trouble affectif à l'entrepreneuriat et
à la créativité
voilà ça a été très dur cette période là
si j'avais 12-13 ans peut-être 14
ça m'a suivi pendant pas mal de temps et
puis un jour cette intuition au fond de
moi a pris le dessus
j'ai transformé cette peur cette colère
en énergie positive et je me suis dit
julian suite et intuition tu as besoin
d'un enseignement plus libre tu as
besoin de quelque chose de créatif
alors j'ai décidé de faire les
beaux-arts ici à orléans et c'est pour
ça que je suis ici devant vous
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai décidé de
poursuivre ce message de revenir à
orléans pour pouvoir vous parler de mon
histoire
cette histoire c'est suite et intuition
crois en toi
ses colères
je les ai transformé en énergie positive
et ses colères aujourd'hui je vais faire
un petit parallèle avec vous je pense qu
on en a tous on en rencontre pour
différents sujets moi mes colères vous
allez voir elles sont assez dérisoire
mais colère c'est les colères qu'on peut
rencontrer au travail peut-être en
voiture pour venir ici tout à l'heure où
dans les transports ou à la maison
ces petits moments de rien ou
vous vous rendez compte que ça aurait pu
être plus simple que les choses auraient
pu être mieux fait je vous partage et
deux exemples voyez cette prison vous la
connaissez c'est la prise qu'en branche
3 x
on a branché dans un sens ça marche pas
normal on la revanche dans un deuxième
sens ne marche pas pas normal on la
revanche dans le troisième sens est en
finale oui il ya bien que 205 et ça
marche toujours pas bon si ça marche la
prise usb
c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe en termes de design c'est en
catastrophe en terme d'échec
moi personnellement j'ai cinq prises à
brancher par jour téléphones portables
tablettes appareils photo numériques les
mêmes la lampe de mon vélo elle se soit
elle se recharge en usb
je multiplie sa part le nombre de
personnes qui ont des prises usb
le nombre de prises usb que chaque
personne a sur terre ça fait quoi 10
milliards d'échec 20 milliards d'échec
en fait j'ai à peu près compter et ça
fait cinquante ça ferait 50 milliards
des chèques d'ergonomie par jour dans le
monde
deuxième exemple
voilà moi quand je fais un baby sitting
avec ma belle mère et que je l'invite à
la maison en fait l angoisse samedi mon
gendre est ce que vous pouvez allumer la
télé avant que je pars avant que vous
partiez bon voilà ouais évidemment je
pense que ça vous fait rigoler parce que
en fait à les cantons les boutons sur la
télécommande 10 20 30 40
et comme pour la prise usb en fait il ya
cinquante bouton sur la sur la
télécommande
voilà combien il faut de doigts pour se
servir de cette télécommande
alors je critique mais bon je sais que
j'ai pas fait de télécommande dans ma
vie j'ai jamais sans inventer de prises
non plus pour brancher de l'informatique
donc je vais plutôt vous poser la
question de comment on fait pour changer
les choses
ça c'est positif comment on fait pour
transformer ses colères transformer ses
craintes ses peurs en énergie positive
moi ma façon de transformer tout ça en
énergie positive c'est de garder un
petit peu de temps dans ma vie pour
enseigner et pour transmettre ce que
j'ai appris pendant 40 ans j'ai un petit
théorème qui est tout simple le coeur
c'est la confiance
le nuage c'est rêver la main c'est faire
les choses et le signe égal barré c'est
la différence
si je le met en mots ça donne je suis
légitime à rêver de tenter de réinventer
nos sociétés la confiance c'est vraiment
le message que je voulais vous passer
aujourd'hui je vais prendre un exemple
en tant qu'enseignant j'enseigne en
master à paris en école de design
j'enseigne aussi à hec à des futurs ceo
de start-up justement et à chaque fois
le message que je transmets c'est bien
d'avoir confiance en soi sans confiance
en soi on ne peut pas réinventer nos
sociétés cet exemple j'ai proposé à mes
étudiants en design de réinventer leur
système d'exploitation qui mieux que des
étudiants qui passent 12 heures par jour
vous rendez vous compte douze heures par
jour sur un ordinateur portable 13
pouces pour juger la qualité de ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur de leur ordinateur est
bien quand je propose à des étudiants de
repenser et de réinventer l'intérieur de
l'ordinateur comme l'interface graphique
de votre téléphone
eh bien ce sont les premiers à avoir des
freins les premiers qui sont
conditionnés équipe et qui ne veulent
pas penser différemment on entendait
mais non les systèmes qu'on a c'est les
meilleures sociétés du monde
impossible de faire de faire
différemment ce qu'on a c'est ce qui est
le plus abouti
on entend aussi ouais moi mon beau frère
il est informaticien à aydie que en fait
on peut pas changer les choses c'est
comme ça c'est pas autrement je les
laisse s'exprimer
j'ai fait travailler en petits groupes
avec des post it et je leur dit bon
écoute et on va pas réinventer les
choses simplement dites moi ce que vous
vous aimez pas dans votre logique dans
votre ordinateur
et là il ya des choses qui sortent
naturellement j'espère comme vous ouais
moi j'en ai marre d'enregistrer moi j'en
ai marre de chercher des fichiers moi
j'en ai marre de classer mes fichiers et
puis il ya des utopies qui apparaissent
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est pouvoir
caresser mon ordinateur et interagir
avec lui un peu comme un flipper le
taper quand je suis pas content ou lui
faire une caresse quand je suis bien
content pourquoi regarder chez dans les
nouveaux ordinateurs aujourd'hui on a
des zones tactiles pour pouvoir
interagir
mais ce qui m'a plus touchée est ce que
j'ai trouvé extraordinaire et que je
vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
c'est que j'ai un groupe d'étudiants qui
m'ont inventé une intelligence
artificielle qui grandit avec eux tout
au long de leur vie et qui les
accompagnent pour pouvoir se nourrir de
tout ce qu'ils allaient faire et ainsi
ne jamais perdre ne jamais avoir à
reconstruire de façon laborieuse des
fichiers des réglages des préférences
etonnant non
est ce que vous connaissez cet homme non
oui c'est ça arrive c'est le célèbre et
discret designer d'apple lui et steve
jobs avait fait un nid un contrat en
place assez intéressant qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui gagnant gagnant steve jobs
avait pas les moyens de pouvoir payer
john hutton hive à la hauteur de ses
brevets qu'il développait à tour de bras
pendant 20 ans pendant vingt ans
johnatan heil a révolutionné
l'informatique grâce à steve jobs
alors il lui a donné des actions contre
ces brevets il a intéressé en lui
donnant des actions d'apple aujourd'hui
apple est la première société cotée en
bourse au monde devant l'industrie
pétrolière et depuis la mort de steve
jobs
john alton hive et la personne physique
sur terre qui a le plus d'actions apple
c'est un designer ce n'est pas un
directeur financier
ce n'est pas un directeur commercial
cette personne a une fortune personnelle
qui a été estimé par des grands médias à
plus de 100 millions de dollars
penser différemment
cindy fiennes ça vous rappelle rien
penser différemment c'est rentable rêver
tenté réinventer c'est rentable alors
non les filières artistiques ne sont pas
des voies de garage
et aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous
transmettre ce message
si je devais me reconnecter au petit
garçon que j'étais en 10e en 6e pardon à
l'âge de 10 ans en 10e ce pas mal en 10e
j'aurais envie qu avec la société me
dise une seule chose ait confiance en
toi réinvente tentes aux faire les
choses tu peux le faire et si je devais
aujourd'hui me connecter à vous et
essayez de vous faire passer un message
ce serait à tous ses petits enfants qui
étaient assis sur le banc avec moi et à
vos enfants à vous et à vos enfants ou
vos futurs enfants pour ceux qui sont
plus jeunes
ayez confiance en eux c'est la seule
façon de changer de société ce ne sera
pas avec tous les designers ergonomes
les meilleurs stylistes avec les ceux
qui savent penser ou ceux qui sont
éthiques ça ne changera rien la seule
façon de changer nos sociétés c'est de
s'autoriser à rêver et pour s'autoriser
arriver il faut avoir confiance en nous
merci
[Applaudissements]